[Music]
first of all
it's i'm absolutely comfortable using
that term because it is rooted in that
academic definition
oftentimes when people you know when the
term concentration camp is
evoked what people think of are
extermination camps they think of
auschwitz and i think what we need to
realize is that
one of the biggest lessons that we learn
from both
holocaust historian civil rights
academics and experts is that it takes a
process a slow gradual process of
increasingly dehumanizing steps
and once you have convinced an
electorate or once you have convinced a
community
that a certain group of people are bad
or less than
it justifies and it allows people to
feel more comfortable
with the dehumanization and the
dehumanizing acts and the violation
of their rights so when you talk about
for example
why the republican party has not joined
us in actively fighting
the actively fighting
horrifying uh separation of children
from their parents
and it clearly doesn't bother them
enough to the point where they will
actually join us in stopping that
um i think that we really need to to
really take a look at
why that is and i think part of it is
because of the dehumanizing rhetoric
towards
immigrant communities really do
change their positions because of the
activism they do all you are engaged in
they listen to you
[Music]
what does that procedure look like are
you going to separate families again in
that process
what there's little to no oversight in
this and what we've seen in the past
is that when this administration decides
to embark on a mass
policy concerning immigrants they botch
it they violate human rights
and people often die in the process
when she said she was trying of course
they were and the ironic part was that
she used
an extremely offensive term
she used the term extermination which is
co-opting the language
of that you know that term implies that
the people who died in the holocaust it
it doubles down on the rhetoric
that justified it and so i think it's uh
i mean i think she's one of these do her
homework
you